one's artificial intelligence a machine
so it doesn't count
no it's not like a person lifting the
hammer right different rules for a nice
guy artificial things but if you put the
hammer in an elevator but still go up
elevators not worthy I'm gonna miss
these little talks of ours huh not if
you don't leave I have no choice right
well done I am running out of things to
say are you ready
[Music]
it's terribly well-balanced well if
there's too much weight you lose power
on the swing keep out darrel costume for
battles the mill near over here taking a
nap little mill near here
our sunglasses in case gets bright and
the Rainbow Bridge which often it does
oh if you lift up this little thing hey
what's he holding me hey youtubers is
Charlie so this is gonna be all about
Thor's hammer in the movies and in the
comics they changed the powers that it
has every once in a while like to
introduce new powers something really
big just happened in the comics so
really big stuff happening with the
hammer in the comics but I'm gonna
explain the movies first so Thor himself
is kind of a ridiculous character so
Marvel naturally sensing this has tried
to add a lot of comedy to his films it
just fits so well you know big dumb
seeming guy it just right for a comedy
so one of the most important things
about Thor's identity is the hammer
so naturally Hammer comedy is a big part
of Thor movies so you have people trying
to lift it up like the Hulk in the first
Avengers film you have vision picking it
up in the second film you have him
bashing Captain America shield with it
like the most comic book II moments you
could possibly think of what happens
when the unstoppable force meets the
immovable object but the hammer itself
has its own identity and now in the
comics they just spelled that out a
little bit more so when you think of
Odin's enchantment whosoever holds this
hammer if he be worthy shall possess the
power of Thor how is it determined
whether or not someone is worthy well
now because of the comics we know that
the hammer does have its own
consciousness it is a lot the hammer is
alive that just makes you think the
hammer is my penis and nathan fillion in
the background just going please put me
in more Marvel movies but if the hammer
is alive are the movies ever going to
address it so with each new Marvel film
they tried to use the hammer in funny
new ways so like vision lifting it up
was like the big thing in Avengers age
of Ultron like oh my god we've never
seen this before somebody else is
wielding Thor's hammer there was even a
deleted scene from Thor the dark world
with Loki lifting Thor's hammer
triumph like everyone was cheering him
it was an illusion that he had created
so it wasn't real
[Applause]
but even if you haven't read the comics
you just get the idea other people have
been able to lift Thor's hammer so back
to the modern movies Captain America has
dropped the shield iron man shots at him
as he's walking away from the fight my
father made that it doesn't belong to
you you know he drops it no it doesn't
belong to me anymore just because he's
left the name Captain America behind
people wondering when is he gonna take
the shield back up when is he gonna
become Captain America again I will say
that he will be worthy of the Captain
America title when he can lift Thor's
hammer the hammer will tell everyone
including Captain America himself that
he's worthy to be Captain America again
so the Russos have said that when we get
to Avengers infinity war the band so to
speak like the family will still be
divorced they'll still be broken up so
they'll probably some moment during that
film or even the second infinity war
film where Captain America becomes
worthy again just the idea being that by
the time that he's worthy again to be
Captain America they'll have also healed
a lot of the wounds between the Avengers
but let me know in the comments do you
think that we'll ever see Captain
America lift Thor's hammer in the Marvel
movies before Chris Evans stops playing
the character in the movies now I think
that he's gonna be Captain America for a
long time it's just that none of the
other characters will call him cap
anymore or they'll call him that is an
honorary title he'd be like don't call
me that I'm not Captain America anymore
they get the idea the hammer is just a
really fun way to tell the story without
actually speaking words like showing
someone you're worthy or us the audience
is much more powerful than telling us
they're worthy so what about the Hammers
powers we've seen all the standard
powers in the movies the ability to
summon lightning giving Thor the power
of flight a certain level of
indestructibility well the new powers
that they just debuted in the comics
that we haven't really seen before is
the ability to manifest a physical
doppelganger so what happens is is like
in the most recent Thor comic the female
Thor Jane Foster is shot with something
called the Mitas bullet so it's like
slowly poisoning her turning her to gold
Mjolnir we also learned has the ability
to leach toxins out of its wielders body
so like if Thor gets
poison and he's holding y'all near the
hammer can slowly draw the poison out so
this whole time she's been the female
Thor shield has been trying to prove
that she's Jane Foster because she's
been hiding her identity from most
people there are a couple people that
know that she's Jane Foster like the
actual Thor he knows that it's Jane
Foster but most people have no idea that
it's her so shield is like okay Thor is
dying unless Jane Foster comes to save
you we are going to take it as proof
that you are secretly Jane Foster so
what happens is is the hammer deeming
her worthy manifests this fake Jane
Foster to come treat actual Jane Foster
and pull the bullet out of her so the
construct that the hammer creates is
really sophisticated it's not just a
hologram it goes way beyond that but the
funny thing is is that she has
absolutely no idea what's going on like
she doesn't know that much about the
hammer the hammer explains to her later
that it deemed her worthy and that it's
not gonna be doing this for a long long
time again so it's not like he can
always create doppelgangers on command
it's just like a very special power that
it can only do every once in a while but
what about other special powers so Stan
Lee debuted the hammer back in the early
60s naturally the stories back then were
a little more whimsical so the hammer
had the ability to open portals through
time it could do pretty much anything
you could imagine any ridiculous power
you could imagine so
later Thor riders have tried to rein
that in a little bit but also use the
hammer and really new interesting ways
so this doppelganger power is just like
the newest thing in that line of powers
I'm not expecting them to ever do it in
the movies but they're you know because
the hammer is enchanted naturally you'd
expect it to be magical Doctor Strange
has crossed paths with it I don't think
they're gonna do this in the movie but
in the comics Doctor Strange has been
able to repair the hammer using the
odinforce that's how powerful the hammer
is that it requires the odinforce one of
the greatest powers in the universe to
repair it but I almost forgot it also
has the ability to change the appearance
of Thor or anybody that wields it so
when he's walking around as Donald Blake
in the comics he has to be holding the
hammer or have it near him for a certain
period of time in order to
maintain the illusion it's kind of like
a version of what Loki does when he
changes his appearance but Loki's magic
is a little more broad spectrum than
Thor's hammer magic but here's the WTF
twist so we know Hulk is in thor
ragnarok wouldn't it be crazy if Hulk
wielded the hammer before Captain
America did I'm not expecting anyone
else to wield Thor's hammer during
Ragnarok but I do think that they will
use the hammer in a slightly different
way like in a way that we haven't seen
before so maybe we'll get more teasers
for the conscious hammer or the
odinforce we're gonna have Ragnarok week
we have Ragnarok monsters to deal with
so naturally they're gonna be doing some
really crazy stuff speaking of which
sam neill has been cast in thor ragnarok
so make all the Jurassic Park Ragnarok
monster jokes that you want we have no
idea who he's playing he could be like
the keeper of the Midgard serpent or he
could just be some random person on the
street one of the reasons why he's
probably in the film is because what TD
just cast him in hunt for the will dirty
before he started shooting Thor Ragnarok
so he's something of a local actor where
they're down there filming Thor Ragnarok
so it just makes sense you know great
actor gonna be awesome in Thor Ragnarok
and I do like the idea that the Ragnarok
monsters are kind of like the dinosaurs
of the Thor universe just like these
really giant powerful terrible monsters
that are from this time Before Time
let me know in the comments what do you
think that Sam Neill is doing in Thor
Ragnarok and what is your favorite
moment with Thor's hammer from the
movies so far
probably the party scene is the funniest
vision lifting it was my oh [ __ ] moment
so just expect some more of that from
the Marvel movies that Thor is in in the
future is gonna be a lot of fun any time
they have an opportunity to do something
crazy with Thor's hammer they will take
it for more Marvel more DC coming later
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything if you guys have any bonus
videos you guys want or any ghost riders
stuff just let me know in the comments
episode 2 of Ghost Rider posting on
Tuesday night while you guys wait for my
next video you can click here to watch
the full funny Thor trailer again you
can click here for my top 10 Justice
League rosters the
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight